mr. president thank you so much for
being here with us today 75th
anniversary of the d-day landing you've
had by all accounts an incredible trip
what lessons are gonna take back home
after this day and your meeting with the
Queen trip to Ireland well first of all
the meeting with the Queen was
incredible I think I can say I really
got to know her because I said were
there many times and we had automatic
chemistry he'll understand that feeling
it's a good feeling but she's a
spectacular woman and the people I met I
met so many veterans and we're talking
about people that have seen it they've
seen days like nobody else and they are
just really incredible people and
feeling this beautiful weather was
raining last night the weather broke
imagining the invasion a hundred and
fifty thousand Allied troops climbing
the cliff landing on these shores what's
going through your mind well this is
weather like they don't normally have
you know this was supposed to be today a
storm and it's a little like the
invasion itself the weather was a big
factor and they delayed it a day and it
worked out okay and you look at the
weather we have we have beautiful
weather it's been this way wherever I've
been I mean we've been now for three and
a half days and it's like I'm saying is
it always like this it's pretty
beautiful but it could be pretty rough
after having met all of these World War
two veterans this entire experience here
today what do you tell the American
people about the importance of this
history and our shared ideals that there
was never a more important battle there
was never a more important event than
the event seventy-five years ago today
think of that these were incredible
brave people who were just being blown
up and you have the the graves all over
I mean these were people that knew they
were
to die it was it was horrendous the
bravery the valor we're giving out
medals today you know we're giving out
medals to certain people in to certain
families this was one of the true in
terms of war in terms of probably you
could also say in terms of peace because
this led to something very special this
was a very very horrific day but it was
also a very special day and it's an
honor to be here two years ago the
so-called experts foreign policy expert
experts we're predicting that you would
fracture NATO America would become
isolationist what do you say to those
experts today well those are the people
that fail so badly and I haven't really
gone to them I know them I've read them
I've seen what their result is and the
result was terrible NATO was going down
if you look at the money coming into
NATO for the last 15 years it's like an
escalator down and now it's like a
rocket ship up secretary Stoltenberg has
been maybe Trump's biggest fan to be
honest with you he goes around to he
made a speech the other day said without
Donald Trump maybe there would be no
NATO we've gotten over a hundred billion
dollars from other countries where
they're starting to pay because we got
to a point where we were paying so much
I think we were really paying close to a
hundred percent of NATO so we weren't
paying to protect all of these European
nations and it's just not fair and I
told them that I told the countries the
heads of the countries I said it's not
fair the United States possibly doesn't
even benefit you know you could make the
case that certainly it in this age that
we're not benefiting certainly not like
them and they paid over a hundred
billion dollars more toward their
defense that's money that we submit was
praising you yesterday for the
burden-sharing that it's basically about
time she was so nice but but they're all
saying it and they're stepping up I
would say Germany has not stepped up
much Germany's paying 1% they should be
paying much more than that one think of
it one percent so we protect Germany and
then Germany takes advantage of us on
trade I was with Angela Merkel yesterday
who I like a lot I have a really great
you know a lot of people think we don't
have a good relationship we do
and Cheban smiles when i said look you
have to pay and she sort of left because
for years they got away with this and
it's unfair and they're not getting away
what about her dig at you when she was
at Harvard was that appropriate what did
she say I want to leave this wish with
you tear down walls of ignorance and
narrow-mindedness
for nothing has to stay as it is she has
to sell justice and you know she took a
pretty tough election a couple of days
ago but I like her I get along with her
but I said you have to pay and most of
the nation's are now either current or
very close to current and that's a
tremendous it's over a hundred billion
dollars in a very short period of time
Mexico tariffs big news back home some
Senate Republicans are a little worried
about this especially economic effects
what must Mexico do what can they do to
stem this massive tide hundred forty
thousand people in May when you're the
piggy bank that everybody steals and
robs from and they deceive you and they
like they've been doing for 25 years
tariffs are a beautiful thing it's a
beautiful word if you know how to use
them properly Republicans should love
what I'm doing because of you tariffs in
two phases number one it's great to
negotiate with because people don't want
to be tariffs for coming into the United
States they don't want that
and number two frankly if they go and
you make a fortune because all the
companies are going to move back into
the country but it's Congress's fault
for not passing Asylum reform so why is
why does it seem like Mexico's because
it's their fault also because they're
letting millions of people walk up
through their country and they shouldn't
let anybody walk up through their
country I mean frankly we shouldn't even
have to have Border Patrol border
patrols doing incredibly you know they
apprehended over a hundred thousand
people less I'd you know forty thousand
and Manuel and what they're doing is
they're taking its and by the way that's
not even close to a record because if
you go back thirteen fourteen years ago
was it was crazy numbers but I don't
want this I want people to come in
Legally we want the people that we want
and I want a merit-based system but we
shouldn't have anybody they shouldn't be
able to walk through a Mexico and now
I've told Mexico if you don't stop this
onslaught this invasion people get angry
when I use
or invasion people like Nancy Pelosi
that honestly they don't know what the
hell they're talking about I watched her
she was saying we have to protect Mexico
we have to take care of Mexico look I'm
dealing with Mexico right now they send
in five hundred billion dollars worth of
drugs they kill a hundred thousand
people they ruin a million families
every year if you look at that that's
really an invasion without the gun are
you worried about how this might affect
the u.s. MCA you're another historic
trade read about it because they need us
we don't need them they need us they
stole 32 percent of our car business
with NAFTA the stupidest they're one of
the truly stupid deals of our time
they stole 32,000 a lie the United
States it's one of our most important
trading partner fine and yet they send
in five hundred billion dollars worth of
drugs we will never do that kind of
trade they send in drugs illegal drugs
five hundred billion dollars a hundred
thousand people are killed dead every
year from what comes through our
southern border they shouldn't be
allowing people to come through their
country from Central from Honduras and
Guatemala El Salvador
she's enough you walk right through our
country we've had Nancy Pelosi as we
were walking up to the stage earlier she
said some pretty harsh things of the
last 24 hours leaked out from her caucus
she said I don't want impeachment I want
him in prison meaning you how do you
work with someone like that I think
she's a disgrace
I actually don't think she's a talented
person I've tried to be nice to her
because I would have liked to have
gotten some deals done she's incapable
of doing this she's a nasty vindictive
horrible person the Muller report came
out it was a disaster for them they
thought their good friend Bobby Muller
was going to give him a great report and
he came out with a report with 13
horrible angry Democrats who were
totally biased against me a couple of
them worked for Hillary Clinton they
then added five more also Democrats with
all of that too
think of it from before I even got
elected they've been going after me and
they have nothing do you mind if he
testifies still before you said he
didn't care my mother doesn't live a he
made such a fool out of himself
the last time she because what people
don't report is the letter he had to do
to straighten out his testimony because
his testimony was wrong but Nancy Pelosi
aquila nervous Nancy Nancy Pelosi
doesn't talk about it Nancy Pelosi is a
disaster okay she's a disaster and let
her do what she wants you know what I
think they're in big trouble because
when you look at the kind of crimes that
were committed and I don't need any more
evidence and I guess from what I'm
hearing there's a lot of evidence coming
in but you look and then ask Nancy why
is her district at drug and needles all
over the place it's the most disgusting
thing what she's allowed to happen to
her district with needles with drug
addicts with people living in the middle
of streets with people living on the
sidewalk you can't go sure to focus on
that because she's a disaster and she
made a statement who's a horrible when
you're overseas vicious statement while
I'm overseas no if I made any statement
about anybody it would be like a big
head why would he do that when he's over
said she didn't want to she is a
terrible person and I'll tell you her
name it's nervous Nancy because she's a
nervous wreck on Tuesday on Joe Biden
once again downplayed the China threat
at one of his he doesn't get it we're in
a position where we have the most agile
venture capitalists in the world it's
not like we're the bad guys they that we
were the best at doing it our workers
are literally three times as productive
as workers in the Far East I mean sue me
in Asia and they're three times
productive what are we worried about how
happy would President Xi be to have Joe
Biden be be the nominee
well he wants art he wants him hey look
we take it in tens of billions of
dollars we had a 3.2 GDP first quarter
it's always 1% less than 1% it's always
the worst what we're 3.2 a point and a
half above schedule you know why because
so much money is coming in from China we
never took in any money from China and
little secret that's only a little tiny
piece of it because the big one is yet
to come we have three hundred and twenty
five billion dollars that I haven't even
taxed yet and they've already spent all
of their weapons they've done everything
again I'll tell you the greatest people
the farmers are Patriot farmers and now
they're really they're gonna benefit
like you and you know remember this
about the farmers for 15 years before I
got here everything was coming down so
this didn't happen the farmers are gonna
be one of the biggest beneficiaries but
these are patriots these are people that
say the president is right and if I'm
going to go through a little short-term
problem it doesn't matter the president
is right listen to those incredible
people back there these people are so
amazing and what they don't realize is
that I'm holding them up because of this
interview but that's because it's you
I'm president by the way congratulations
on your ratings I thank you very much
and President Xi and President Putin sat
down yesterday announced new trade deals
talked about their closer warmer
relationship your reaction to that
especially because you did want to have
a better relationship if possible with
Russia at the beginning of your term is
that out the window now is it not all
have a good relationship with Russia
I think it's hurt by the phony
witch-hunt you know I could have a good
relationship with Russia again we have
what everyone wants I've built an
economy that's incredible
we're up 14 trillion dollars in value
look at what's going on with the stock
market and this is despite a Federal
Reserve that frankly should have had
lower interest rates and everything else
now there's a safety net that's good and
it's more conservative but if we didn't
have all these interest rate you know I
thought he was gonna raise interest
rates all but if we didn't have that
we'd be at 5.2 and the stock market
would be up 10,000 points more but now
we have a very conservative approach and
wisdom we've created trillions of
dollars in value and by the way China
has lost trillions of dollars in value
if somebody else let's say the opponent
who shouldn't have even been allowed to
you know she happens to be a crooked
person so her name was very appropriate
but if she ever won our I would say
China right now would be far ahead of
the United States just think of it
China would have been a we are now so
far ahead of China it's not even a
contest what could you do to unite the
country at a time of great polarization
what else could you do so I think
success should unite the country but I
will tell you the more successful we
become the more angry people like Nancy
Pelosi who don't have what it takes that
they don't know what's going on if they
get angry they should an example is
Mexico I said we're going to put tariffs
on because we want you to help us with
because they won't pass any legislation
in Congress and I have senators and
others and Pelosi coming out saying oh
how horrible what they're doing is
they're hurting a deal they should be
saying we're with the president will do
whatever he wants to do and Mexico would
fold like an umbrella now I have these
people and I'm saying there's some
Republicans too I think they should be
ashamed of themselves but we have Pelosi
we have cry and Chuck Schumer who's a
disaster by the way is a total political
you know jerk but we have Schumer we
have all these people they come out and
they talk about a tariff so there's a
thick killing they are they hurt my
negotiation because I go into the room
with the Mexicans I'm asking them for
everything and by the way if they don't
do it I'm putting the tariffs on we're
gonna make a fortune one thing with the
tariffs when those tariffs go on
companies are going to start moving back
once they know they're going to stay on
companies are going to move back to the
United States they took 32 percent of
our car industry those all every single
one of those plants will move back into
the United States you're gonna get a
deal with China yeah I'll definitely get
a deal with China I mean they want to
make a deal now I will say I'd want to
get a deal but what they did was very
bad we had a deal and they tried to
renegotiate they can't do that what do
you pray for when you pray for this
country peace really peace and we build
up our military we built up our wealth
we've built up everything our country is
in such great shape right now Iran is in
a much different position than they were
two and a half years ago two and a half
years ago Iran is a disaster for us now
there they've got problems let's put it
that way they're not the same country
North Korea no nuclear tests I have a
good wheel and we'll see what happens
we're gonna see what happens
China wants to make a deal everybody
wants to make a deal with the best we're
the strongest there's nobody even close
mr. president finally did you or did you
not the world wants to know
fist bump with the Queen I did not but I
had a great relationship we had a really
great time there are those that say they
have never seen the Queen have a better
time a more animating time we we had a
period where we were talking solid
straight I didn't even know who the
other people at the table were never
smoked up we did we just had a great
time didn't I keep the conversation yes
I am she is a spectacular woman an
incredible woman mr. president thank you
very thank you so much good luck wheeler
take care it is all right by the way
some of you may have heard or read that
president Trump supposedly held up the
entire D Day ceremony in order to do
this interview with me that is patently
false fake news our cue to end the
interview was when we heard the McCrone
helicopter approaching and that is what
we did the interview ended before McCraw
and landed in fact President Trump was
on the lawn waiting for President Makran
who himself was just a few minutes late